to to the internet
so we we're we came up with a billion
200 million dollars in infrastructure to
make sure every single Community rural
communities and others well that's the
case all around the world and so we're
uh this digital connectivity we're
teaming up with a range of Partners to
ensure people have access to the
internet affordable access to Internet
and other Technologies we quad these
Technologies are required to participate
in today's economies and for example
we're working together with Japan and
Australia to upgrade networks and Papua
New Guinea and across the Pacific
improving security performance and
access to Digital Services
and through the United States digital
investment Blended Finance program we're
working with Kenya partner c squared to
establish a nationwide fiber Network in
Liberia that's going to help connect one
million Librarians to the web
and the next is Health infrastructure
we've seen over the last few years
strengthening Health security must be
must be a priority for all of us we just
went through a long discussion on that
that's why we're continuing to support
vaccine Manufacturing in Africa and Asia
and investing 15 million dollars through
the U.S International Development
Finance Corporation in India's Health
infrastructure and just a few examples
and finally gender equity and gender
equality
when we invest in equal opportunity for
women we can deliver greater prosperity
for everyone for everyone
and so we're working with the G7 Nations
and the World Bank to launch the invest
in child care initiative to help
families get children they need get the
child care they need and help women get
the opportunities they deserve to be
able to be in the workforce we're
already starting to see returns for
example the initiative has funded a
project in Somalia and that will help
nearly 300 000 women across the country
to build literacy and Leadership skills
these are just some of the projects
where our countries are stepping up to
deliver impact Investments and we're at
an inflection point Investments we make
today will have far-reaching impact on
the world for generations to come if we
don't make them also have far-reaching
impacts if we don't make these
Investments
and so creating real opportunity greater
equality and more secure healthy and
prosperous world is what we're all about
moving forward we have to continue to
invest together and invest stronger and
we welcome all who share this Vision to
join this partnership I want to thank
you and I would like to turn it over to
a man we haven't heard from for the last
few days
it's all years ago
the magazine President Biden
does initiative inside event partnership
for Global infrastructure and investment
gii
Indonesia is
fiscal
[Music]
s is
mandiri
foreign
foreign foreign
sustainable infrastructures
foreign
foreign
we have discussed
um throughout this day that we live in a
truly volatile global economy with
obviously changing climate and on top in
addition we see that Russia's War
is rubbing salt in the wound of the
economic recovery of covet 19.
so this mixture made us completely
re-evaluate our energy our trade and our
security relationships
what is the situation for the European
Union we are have decided to diversify
completely away from the Russian fossil
fuels
we have understood and learned our
lesson that it was an unhealthy
dependency unsustainable
and we want reliable and forward-looking
connections
and this is why we are launching the
partnership for Global infrastructure
and investment
pgii
we're joining forces to give our
partners a powerful and a positive offer
you have said uh dear Joe the world
needs a positive investment boost this
is what it's all about
to help build the global infrastructure
that we all need for sustainable growth
so invest in renewable energy in
transport corridors in digital
connections that people can trust
from the European side the contribution
is the so-called global gateway
it's our 300 billion euros investment
program for abroad for the next five
years
combined with the wish to harness the
power and the knowledge of the private
sector
and we're deeply convinced that this
will be a game changer
for two reasons first of all global
gateway or pgii
is not just investing massively in the
state-of-the-art infrastructure but is
also investing in the local capacities
of our partners this is crucial we want
to strengthen our shared resilience we
have been discussing in the last session
the vaccine manufacturing example
what is special about it
if we take the example from the European
Union there is a European American
company
that is sharing its mRNA technology
and training local professionals so it's
about skills
then we have African and European
financial institutions that are
providing the investment
and we have our regulatory medicines
agency that are sharing their know-how
no single actor
in this combination could have done this
alone but together we're able really to
deliver on the ground
and my second point is that the
partnership for Global infrastructure
and investment
is working because it is demand driven
we see a a
enormously Rising demand for renewable
energy and this is a good example
as I said Europe has decided to
diversify completely away from the
Russian fossil fuels and we want to
LeapFrog
to clean energy
we need this clean energy not only to
have it homegrown but also to import it
our partners in the global South
have an abundance of clean energy
potential and resources
so Europe could turn into the world's
largest market for their energy exports
what is necessary is investment and
infrastructure and that's where we have
to tune up team up so some examples at
cop27 we've signed hydrogen Partnerships
with Namibia Egypt and Kazakhstan or
with Namibia we're building transport
corridors from the Indian Ocean to the
Atlantic Port of Albus Bay
and there's much more to be done
I'm very happy that today we launch the
Just Energy transition partnership with
Indonesia a big step forward
team Europe will contribute over 1
billion euros it is the road map for the
country's low carbon future and we are
investing in developing geothermal
energy
or we are engaged in talks with India
for renewable hydrogen with Chile for
critical raw materials or we are
launching a digital Alliance in Latin
America to build a fiber optic cables
and satellite connectivity many many of
these examples show exactly the
direction of travel and the shared
interest that we do have so we are ready
to contribute
if we align our investment strategies
and crowd in the private sector that is
crucial I think we can maximize our
joint impact let's bundle our forces and
make a positive difference in investment
globally
now I have the pleasure to invite the
heads of states to deliver their remarks
and I hand over the floor to Japan's
prime minister kishida fumio you have
the flow
is
[Music]
Indonesia
[Music]
investment energy
realizing the theme of the G20 chosen by
Indonesia recovered together recover
stronger
offer the next five years Japan aims to
spend no less than 65 billion dollars
through infrastructure assistance and
mobilization of private sector funds
a typical example infrastructure
investment is engaged
in Indonesia through food construction
Japan and automobile terminal operated
by the company with Japanese Capital
both the capacity of the existing Port
will be mitigated and investment climate
to be improved with support from Japan
our assistance focuses on transfer of
advanced technology and development
using assistance from Japan the people
of India through their own efforts
created an organization that ensures
safety and precision and operations and
maintenance
investment in clean infrastructure also
serves as a counter measure against
climate change in Kenya Japan is
supporting the construction and
renovation of geothermal power
generators that account for 1 7 of the
dolphin power generated in their country
another initiative that will contribute
to the 1.5 degree Target is the launch
of the Just Energy transition
partnership with Indonesia which we very
much welcome
to Japan along with the United States
will lead the partnership as a joint and
Lead country
by gaining further engagement
realistic and ambitious transition for
decarbonization in Indonesia will be
accelerated
in the additional area Australia is
driving an Initiative for the
development of an ICT company which
covers six Civic United Nations Japan
with the United States plans to support
this project it is important that
infrastructure projects and development
Finance for their funding be implemented
in a transparent and fair manner that
follows the G20 principles or quality
infrastructure investment and complies
with International goals and standards
under rg7 presidency next year again
Japan with strong determination will
promote over the infrastructure
investment collaborate with our partners
and support the self-resilient group of
countries
thank you
that's the next
um one is just introduce
[Music]
[Music]
of course you want something that we
need to continue so many ways to
incentivize raise your private sections
[Music]